[Music]
surrounded by stunning lakes and close
to two major ski resorts cordeline is
one of idaho's premier vacation
destinations it's also home to the
roosevelt inn
the inn is a 16 bedroom converted school
house owned and run by one of its former
students john hoff
the roosevelt inn
is the first hotel i've ever actually
owned i was up here signing the papers
and i called my wife tina and i say we
now own the roosevelt inn and all of a
sudden i hear this
because she started crying
i did not want to buy the hotel but john
really did i have told john many times
that he won't be cold in the ground and
i'm on my way home to kentucky
the roosevelt inn is not just hell for
tina it's hell for the guests who have
to put up with the consequences of
john's eccentric behavior sorry we're
not trying to be a pain yes you are i
would say that the hotel is struggling
because it's dated it's old it kind of
smells funny though it smells old
probably because it is old
and the food coming out of the inns
shoebox size kitchen
is as bad as the decor
oblivious to the problems john's
performance never stops i'll ask you
questions you'll give me answers i'll
ask questions you'll give answers i'll
ask you questions you'll give me answers
as john is more focused on playing
dress-up how was that watson than on
being an innkeeper john refuses to grow
old gracefully it's halloween for john
every day he loves to dress up it's the
cass it's the bloody cat once a month at
the roosevelt we put on a murder mystery
and dinner other thing going in here for
you fine okay i basically do everything
uh you wanna finish making up this bed
and i'll do the bathroom okay great i
feel my dad doesn't appreciate my mom my
mom works three times harder than my dad
does there are times that i'll come in
and she's out busy doing something and
he's sitting on the couch reading a book
as the business has suffered so has john
and tina's relationship
we actually had to go through marriage
counseling i don't think john
understands the sacrifice i've made
unless i can get this place on the road
to recovery john and tina will lose
everything
if i lose the roosevelt i don't just
lose my job i lose my home i become
unemployed
and homeless in one fell swoop dang it i
don't think we're gonna pull out of this
one
i'm here in cur de lane idaho i
seriously hope this place is better than
the other shitholes i've stayed in oh my
god
look at that they say all publicity is
good publicity but the billboard that
old fashion
i'm not so sure
you're [ __ ] joking aren't you come on
roosevelt in bed and breakfast it's like
something about the adams family
roosevelt school
the place looks grim from the outside
hello welcome to the roosevelt good to
see you i recognize that voice you're
gordon ramsey okay well go see you my
god look at those chairs there are they
from the school they are those came out
of the first grade classroom well look
you almost fit are you reception for
dwarves or just
first impression from the outside it's
almost like walking to your funeral
parlor oh
it smells like [ __ ] as well what is that
is that did the dog let's do it oh boy i
sure hope not oh rohan
jesus
this is our dining room who's the chef
here i saw a billboard of a guy with the
most hideous hat on
covered in trees and like this six foot
hat
it's kind of uh grown into jean-pierre's
mad french chef with the roosevelt
because you're in coeur d'alene is a
french name town you know so we must
cook some fabulous food avoid this
outfit
now you'll see uh school photos yes down
the hallway here and these are of kids
that went to school here at the
roosevelt and the ones with the arrows
pointing at the really cute adorable
little boy that's me of course because i
went to school here are you going to see
my elementary school
who wants to live in their old school
it's like getting a detention that never
ends the guests get to hang out down
here with the dogs and watch tv you are
kidding me
you can't smell those dogs oh yes i can
the dogs actually believe it or not
gordon
are one of the highlights here
now you're standing deluded
what's next our little ballroom or our
multi-purpose room oh come on rohan
you're not supposed to be in this room
don't you think this place could at
least had some form of makeover well
sadly gordon we renovated this room four
years ago
this is new
stop no this room looks like it was last
decorated in 1908 not 2008. how much do
you spend on this fifty four thousand
fifty four thousand five four
yeah not fifty four hundred fifty four
thousand i know lovely huh christ i'm
writing and does it generate money no
i can't believe anyone would want to
rent that space it's hideous
i'm dying to have a look upstairs it
can't get any worse it could get worse
and what's your uh occupancy across the
year probably around mid-20s 20
across the board ouch
i'm amazed you find it so funny this is
your room
okay what's with all the pink it's like
someone threw a strawberry milkshake all
over the place my room has two levels
each as bad as the other oh
everything looks like we're in a time i
mean it's so dated
so my room how much do you pay to stay
in here uh 319.
319
bloody how
i'm speechless
13 year old decor 319 a night can i ask
you something fire away why do you think
everything's a big joke
because you're
very critical i'm here to get this place
right but what i don't understand is how
blase you are
to the situation i am going to give you
the truth and if you don't like that
then i'm out of here what do you want me
to do get angry and punch you you want
to punch me
you go fast maybe i do want to punch you
a little bit but i can become physically
very very violent
and have in the past people get hurt
[Music]
john john
you can't just walk away
where are you going
[Music]
since i checked into idaho's roosevelt
inn i've been unimpressed by the
horrible decor what's with all the paint
it's like someone's vomiting everywhere
and the dated event space that smells
like wet dog the dogs actually are one
of the highlights here but the biggest
problem here is the owner john who seems
to think it's funny that he's in is a
disgrace the only time he stopped
laughing was when i confronted him with
how bad things really are here what i
don't understand is how blase you are to
the situation here's your keys
jump you can't just walk away
while john hides on the truth downstairs
i'm gonna have a closer look at my room
it's like someone's ashes
an absolute mess
that's what the rug's on the floor for
just gross
look at the dust on there most
disgusting of all [ __ ] is the dust
magnet hanging over my pillows
[Music]
how long has that thing been up there
help
let me out
i hope i'll get a sense of what's really
going on here from john's wife tina
gordon this is my lovely wife how are
you i'm stressed out um what hotel were
you running before this i was running a
dental office i worked in a dental
office i wasn't running anything except
my home so why would you go from sort of
teeth to a hotel because he bought a
hotel
so you bought the hotel it was
my negotiation
you negotiated you both bought it yes
willingly or unwittingly unwillingly
i was very happy and content with the
life that we had so when john told me
that we were buying the roosevelt i
burst into tears how much did you buy
for seven hundred thousand seventy five
how much you spent on it we owe one
million one hundred thousand oh so you
haven't paid back the debt yet to the
bank owned huh yeah no the bank owns
that we sold our house we had here
cashed in a 401k everything we had oh my
word uh where's your house now what do
you live in we live up in the attic
building
this is my health
i have had
terrible experiences here
business experience financial hardship
everything's just falling apart here for
me
you seem serious you seem joking it's
almost like you're playing at it it is
kind of an entertainment though
to a certain degree uh 1.1 million
dollars that's an expensive
entertainment well yeah
i didn't realize it was this bad how's
the relationship we were in a rough
place
we went through marriage counseling what
was that four or five years ago
because of this business oh yeah and
still working together seven days a week
yes 24 7.
i'm ready for something to change i'm
ready for anything at this point i just
feel like i'm
i'm gonna suffocate i'm gonna get my uh
bag unpacked and i'll uh i'll catch up
with you later thank you
tina looks ready to bail out and all
john can do is laugh he thinks being
over a million dollars in debt is
entertainment i think this marriage is
in as much trouble as the inn clearly in
denial but
more importantly
a man that won't man up and take
responsibility
[Music]
i've been told that tonight the
roosevelt inn is holding a murder
mystery dinner it's an event they host
once a month i have a feeling it's gonna
be hard to forget
and if you'll head on into there i'll
get you all checked and ready to go you
look fabulous we usually always have a
lot of fun with this we're going to
continue to have fun with this are you
dressing that for the ceiling i play the
part of sherlock holmes
you're playing an englishman i am
playing an englishman and i even have
the pipe to go with it
i've studied this accent long and hard
in fact mine is better than your british
accent
i actually don't know where gordon got
his accent he obviously doesn't practice
it very much mine is far more authentic
than his is
absolutely yes wow
while jon prances around as sherlock
holmes i wonder what tina does during
these events
oh my gosh what happened got on this is
crazy
what happened to you it's murder mystery
night sir it's gone from an end to
little house of prairie
i mean honestly it'll be my job this
evening to cook your dinner so while
john gets to play sherlock holmes his
wife is stuck in the kitchen wake up
john this is not the 1800s anymore john
definitely liked dressing up more for
the murder mysteries because he's not in
the hot kitchen he's out there hamming
it up with the guests playing sherlock
holmes okay
right um i'm not
too sure what to make of all this is a
little bit bizarre
slightly weird
i wonder if this event even makes any
money
is this profitable
it is profitable
yeah it's a lot of work i mean we made
200 tonight 200
for all this work and are they all
staying over oh no most of the locals
you know when they come for a murder
mystery they usually don't do it
overnight
clearly tonight's about feeding john's
ego not filling his bank account oh well
that that could explain it then no oh
here now here now oh my word
i say oh my [ __ ] god hell
come true sir
ladies and gentlemen it appears the game
is afoot you know the goal with the
murder mysteries has always been to get
people in but i'm not filling the rooms
what's the point
[Music]
and i would have called away with the
two if it wasn't for you and your
meddling guests
well there you have it brilliant of all
of you
thank goodness that's over it's time to
find out from john what on earth he
thinks he's doing
sit down you must be shattered i'm tired
i bet you uh stick a fork in me matt was
it mad yeah
you're in the kitchen busting your ass
off working
hard to serve all those people and john
you were out prancing around like a sort
of actor this is the thespian thing it's
an inn it's not a theater
but you seem to enjoy it you have to
force yourself to like doing it i mean
it's on stage for three hours
[Music]
the problems at the roosevelt
can i just have a word with you on your
own
oh sure
this place is sinking because john
refuses to take anything seriously
you love
being an entertainer don't you dare tell
me that that is hard
this whole [ __ ] thing was put
together for your fantasy well that's
kind of what this night is
it is entertainment we put on a show
you're pretending to be sherlock holmes
and upstairs we're empty
you're in the [ __ ] financially we're in
ruins and if you put the same amount of
effort into filling this place just one
room book tonight would have made more
profit than the whole murder mystery and
all that work that went into it i mean
this is insane
and you prance around like some [ __ ]
idiot
while your wife is slaving away in the
kitchen do you have any care in the
world apart for yourself
when you get a psychology degree oh when
i go you come and tell me what's wrong
with me here we go you obviously think
you are a psychologist denali again no
i'm not in denial i just don't know what
you want it's only your own [ __ ]
stupidity to why we're in the [ __ ] this
far well that is probably true so then
man up
and act responsible
[Music]
okay i'm done with that
oh i'm done with that
now
a bit more no just talk to my hand you
know i talked to my hand oh what a
[ __ ] idea you're not 10 years old you
need to grow up and stop running away
from the truth
[ __ ] joke it was a rough first day at
idaho's roosevelt inn
let me out and last night proved to me
that owner john needs to stop dressing
up wait till i get going and start
growing up you prance around like some
[ __ ] idiot and take some
responsibility for the problems at the
end it's only your own [ __ ] stupidity
to why we're in the [ __ ] i'm done with
that but john didn't want to listen just
talk to my hand you know i talked to man
oh what a [ __ ] idiot
[Music]
today
i'll have another go at getting through
to him before he heads into the kitchen
to prepare lunch
you're losing money you're on this
treadmill of mistake after mistake we
may be in a elementary school but you're
not a child and i would really wish if
you stop acting like one quickly is that
possible
sure
show me what you got
can you get that i don't want to cook
for gordon i mean first of all he's got
a huge ego of his own so you know
nothing anybody else does is going to be
any good i don't even want to cook him a
thing how are we doing over here
word of spread that i'm in town and the
dining room is full we're all having the
same five course set menu cooked in the
inn's tiny kitchen
shrimp cocktail to starch off
thank you
um that's probably the tomato juice
unless it's condensation from the shrimp
condensation was it frozen
yes
and everyone else seems to be hating it
too how can you [ __ ] up
here's gordon's pecan crusted salmon is
it fresh salmon frozen frozen that has
to be the saddest looking plate of
salmon anywhere in north america tonight
[Music]
no seasoning
it's very dry
would you like me to take it for you yes
please i'm sorry i'll take care of it
tastes great to me
i'm gonna kill him i just want gordon to
take a long walk off a short pier i want
him to fall into a very deep pit
so he can't get out
this is pathetic can john cook anything
can we cook an egg
he can cook an egg could you ask him
just to boil me an egg sure
he can't possibly mess up a soft-boiled
egg can he soft-boiled egg
okay what soft-boiled egg
what
i'm just like going
wow
[Music]
i'll make my own egg cup i can't help
i was wrong
is this really happening he can't even
boil a [ __ ] egg
[ __ ] thing's still got feathers on it
could have probably cooked out another
two minutes
i am absolutely ready to boot gordon
ramsay out of my hand
fire away buddy
are you having a laugh at your family's
expense no
big tall hat big jacket
and you can't boil a [ __ ] egg you
want a
fried egg
you want french toast too how about some
pancakes what the [ __ ] are you doing
you don't care dude
i do care
you're a [ __ ] joke
those are what we refer to as fighting
words gutsy thing to do especially in a
kitchen full of sharp knives it has
never been a joke for me i've come play
at my school i'm the headmaster
you're acting like an absolute idiot no
but you're in my house that's right i'm
disgusted at your performance your big
problem is you can't handle the truth
you don't like hearing it you don't even
know me you know it's a joke think about
your wife
you're in to 1.1 million dollars of debt
you're forcing her to live in hell she's
telling me that i just think over the
last 13 years but what you've [ __ ]
done
and not to you
to everyone standing behind you i'm
tired of hearing that i don't need it
anymore
screw it
i really don't care if he leaves [ __ ]
man
i had a horrible night sleep on the
couch because i couldn't sleep in my bed
i really need a hot shower
[Music]
[ __ ] you now this water's freezing i
need to open john's eyes but he walks
out every time things get difficult so
i've got another plan have you got two
minutes we do there's something i'd like
to uh show you
both in my uh my room oh crap
what now
what's wrong
now
please come through oh
[Music]
there's the jury
and they're going to hang us clearly you
recognize some of your guests for the
past six months we do i think feedback
is critical first impressions walking
through the door a lot of decorations
it's kind of outdated how date is here
too much a lot going on at once
i'd like to go on to the food um the
general consensus
it was too it wasn't the value that we
paid honestly
show of hands how many of you would
return and stay here again please
none of our guests would return
i'm kind of speechless i i'm i i didn't
expect this i thought it was i thought
we were better than that that's the most
valuable information you've had in 13
years i thought we were a lot better
than this and that that is uh a view
that is changing you've got to put
yourself in the guest position
you know you've given me feedback on
everything you've seen and experienced
but there's something i'd like to point
out that none of you see
please
would you be so kind to put a pair of
these on please
oh my gosh can this just get
any more terrible i don't think so
lassie's on
okay this black light is gonna show up
any bodily fluids
let's start with the uh the pillow show
get there
oh
my god
like someone urinated on it
absolutely disgusting
if you think that's bad
this kind of stuff hasn't been weeks
that's that's years
[Music]
absolutely hideous horrified
disgusted grossed out kind of want to go
vomit
you kind of trust that things are going
to be you have the right and you you
have that this is just as bad as it can
possibly be i mean i'm disgusted i
how does that make you feel it makes me
actually feel sick to my stomach that i
slept i thought i took a shower but now
i'm wondering about the shower
i'll let you go thank you thank you
thank you all very much thank you
this is me i mean i've put my heart and
soul into this
it's just so embarrassing
i had to do this because you won't
listen to me and john just laughs at
every problem i understand
i understand now
i'm worried about tina hearing from the
guests and seeing those stains seem to
hit her pretty hard tina yes have you
got two sex
come on
i'm not here to hurt you i'm here to
help you i'm just
banging my head against the wall with
john well i know what we do is not
perfect but i thought what we did was
better than that john's got to get out
of this bubble
he's an innkeeper
but he's constantly joking and shrugging
responsibility and now he has to start
looking at himself
the thing that
probably bothers me the most is john
just refuses to understand my need to
have my part of the dream i don't like
living and eating and breathing my work
24 7 and never ever having a place to go
that i can get away
no
i'm not
at the end of the day i usually lay down
the bed and i know this is what i wanted
and i'd leave here tomorrow if i could
leave here tomorrow i'm ready to just
walk away from this and just forget it i
want to leave i want to get out of here
and go away
you can't
give up 13 years of being unhappy is not
a mobile it's a mountain do you have a
voice you've got to stand up you
absolutely have the right to be happy
i mean
i guess maybe i needed somebody to say
you have a right to be happy
so that was good thank you
i'll see you later
i promise you i'll make a difference and
i mean that
last night john's wife tina was at a
breaking point but you're not happy
oh
and i'd leave here tomorrow if i could
leave here tomorrow after talking i
realized how bad things really are here
and i promise to make things better
because tina truly deserves to be happy
good morning good morning how are you
i'm
i'm here you're here
um
let's catch up shall we let's get out of
this little cubby hole okay um
maybe downstairs
i can't believe that john and tina has
spent 60 thousand dollars on a ballroom
that they never use and smells like dog
looking at this inn
there's a
huge missed opportunity
the potential of this room is
extraordinary and
this has to be used as a way to get
people into the bedrooms upstairs and
make money
exactly how often do you use this room
twice a month fortnite that's crazy it
is have you ever thought about employing
a wedding planner to actually book this
place out i have one that i'm working
with
i've been working with her for just
about a year now i don't pay her a
salary it's her wedding if we score a
wedding we both get paid so she's
motivated to sell it
for me it's a big missed opportunity
yeah once you've held an amazing wedding
and you've got such great feedback it
just spreads
okay that's what i want to see um i'll
see you later yeah
thank you
this does not stack up
i'm gonna go meet the wedding planner
because
there must be something that jon and
tina aren't telling me
hello how are you nice to meet you my
wife where should we start well you want
to come on over and we'll have a seat
shall we yes come on over
the roads about um what would you say
the key
problems it's dated it's um it's hard to
sell 10-day old bread
you know brides are young they're
sophisticated they're on their phones
they're seeing what the rest of the
world is doing you know a big thing with
selling the ballroom is the colors that
only matches a tiny percentage you can
either go burgundy ivory or navy blue
and those colors are so dated anyways
dog it's terrible and then you walk
downstairs and the smell i had one girl
literally say i've got to go upstairs
the smell is going to make me sick
john doesn't
strike me as someone that i'd want to
put my wedding in his hands as a host
how is he we have had some issues um
last summer with him coming out and
dancing
at the guest wedding yes like ballroom
dancing or it was more like macarena
type line dancing style oh my god i mean
how awkward was that it was mortifying
if you just bear with me whilst i make
some changes
because i mean
you are the key to their success going
forward
would you give them one more chance
okay i'm in
thank you good to see you too good to
see you thank you thank you
now that misty's on board to help the
roosevelt i'm gonna make one last
attempt to see if john is ready to
change
how you feel
[Music]
i'm not here to hurt your feelings john
but you have a huge defense mechanism i
have an attitude i want to help but you
are a very tough stubborn
selfish individual to get through to
truth hurts it's not a sign of weakness
to put your hand up and ask for help
[Music]
and i don't want bads
i don't want to butt heads either
gordon i've got two options here i can
close up the business
walk away from it give it to the bank
the other option is
i know i've done this to myself i've
done this to my wife
i've got to find a way to get out of it
this has been your dream your ambition
and she just followed suit
you're correct you have one amazing
loyal lady
i don't deserve her
i'm a pig sometimes there's just no
doubt about it
yeah trying to change that
she's not the one that should be
suffering because of what i did and
i haven't even considered that in years
let's start making this place better i
need you committed i want the help
i want to make this work
[Music]
now that john's finally turned the
corner i'm a pig sometimes trying to
change that it's time to sit down with
tina and get to the heart of their
relationship i'm so pleased that we've
got a place that we can start making
steps in the right direction this is a
family run in and you
need your time out and you need to cut
your dear lady slack you need to learn
the importance of being a happy couple
what have you got to say yeah
we've been so wrapped up in this
and everything we do that
we just
don't even know where to where to go
with romance anymore it's like
i'm so self-consumed
with
all of this
just the ability to just
have a conversation with you
understanding my my feelings i have
wishes and ambitions are things that
are important to me
that are vitally important to me
you have to support that if you're not
prepared to support each other in each
other's roles then it's never ever going
to work you need to be happy together i
want to know what your dreams are again
i haven't heard a dream from you
in years
i don't even know what your dreams are i
don't know what my dreams are anymore
i've i've
quit dreaming i want you to start
dreaming again
and then i want you to share those
dreams with me
[Music]
because i love you
i know you do told all my girls they
were princesses
and you are too
i haven't treated you much like royalty
i do feel that gordon has helped john
appreciate me more and see what's going
on inside of here
should matter to him
now that they're talking again i want to
give tina and john a lesson in something
else they've not done well for a long
in time in
country hotel it's all about comfort and
what i learn immediately from you is
that you're trying way too hard
you've got a shoe box
of a kitchen that you can't swing a cat
in you shouldn't be cooking five course
meals in there
okay you're not a chef no i'm not you
shouldn't be on a billboard that
shouldn't be a delicious home-cooked
meal that's all i'd expect to see that's
all expect to smell when you come
through that door so i put together
a list of dishes for the whole week
something you can cook in one pot
fabulous let it cook itself really
fabulous these are my recipes i'm proud
of them don't start improvising changing
just follow them they will work half an
hour to get the chili on yeah
fabulous
nobody comes here john and tina
expecting a five-course meal the food
was an amazing discovery that it could
be so simple so easy so delicious i'm
glad that gordon is in my kitchen
tomorrow is a new dorm for the roosevelt
and my goodness are we going to turn the
page
my team worked all night to bring the
hotel into the 21st century
now it's time to reveal the new
roosevelt inn good morning good morning
good morning spring in your step john
how you feeling wonderful good let's go
come here come in come in please okay 16
rooms 32 guests this hotel should be
full
welcome to your new honeymoon suite oh
wow
oh my god wow
john how do you feel
this is incredible gordon honeymoon
sweet
decluttered bright elegant
we were literally two centuries back in
time with what we were doing in these
rooms and we are suddenly into now
today it's
amazing john and tina i'd like you both
to go upstairs
[Music]
very pretty this is just classy a room
that will be great for room service to
have a bit of romance oh this is just
truly beautiful now coupled with selling
those rooms the big
asset that was underused in many ways
was downstairs truly that's been a huge
disappointment for me come with me now
let me show you the new
stunning roosevelt wedding space
i thought we had something that would be
viable to help build our business and it
wasn't it was dragging it down oh good
grief oh
[Music]
look at this
whoa
okay this is stunning this is amazing
[Music]
this is the direction we need to be
going in this is the next step up and i
am extremely grateful and i don't want
to see a dog
a dog's hair a dog's chew anywhere in
this space
now this room should propel this
business to greater heights it has to be
your biggest marketing tool because when
you got the wedding booked the guest
should book every room upstairs
this space and the revenue it can bring
in to the roosevelt could definitely be
the game changer that we've been looking
for i'd like to
point your attention to those wonderful
plates and all the glassware on the
tables
that's a special gift to you worth fifty
thousand dollars
no way really
you've now got
you know a solid foundation to host the
most amazing wedding beautiful beautiful
now there's someone i'd like you to meet
hey
please this is just you may recognize
this lady
look at our new space
i hope misty's gonna give us a second
chance what strikes you now walking
through that room what's the first thing
that hits you it's just it's natural
it's it's modern it's what the brides
are looking for they're sophisticated
they're young this is what they want and
does it show sort of versatility in a
way that it can be adapted to suit
different colors absolutely we can put
any color in this room and it'll be
wonderful
this is gonna sell itself how does it
smell it smells wonderful
[Laughter]
now here's the good news she is prepared
to give you one more chance to become
kurta lens number one venue for hosting
weddings one more surprise john and tina
missy's not just here to visit the
roosevelt
is hosting a wedding tonight tonight
[Music]
owners of the roosevelt inn john and
tina have come a long way from when i
first met them personally because i love
you and professionally i want to make
this work and i've just surprised them
with a true test for their business the
roosevelt is hosting a wedding tonight
wow
tonight when gordon said we had a
wedding tonight
instant gut clenching terror you're
going to be cooking serving just simple
elegant food
now good luck
[Music]
are you my bride i'm the brown hello
welcome let me just take you ladies up
to the room all right go on in ladies
oh my dress guests are just starting to
arrive hi
i gave john and tina a couple of simple
but delicious wedding recipes that they
could cook in their tiny kitchen and
that i knew the guests would love
this evening is going to be huge for us
you're feeling that that really wound up
sense inside yourself and it's like holy
cow
donald
nicole as the couple exchanged their
vows downstairs
upstairs in the kitchen
john and tina are proving they are there
for each other when it matters
i give you all that i am i give you all
that i am and you may kiss your bride
[Music]
you're that side on this side and we go
bang
and then we go bang and then so now we
have plates and hands guys and down here
okay ladies let's go grab them and go
grab them and go
for the first time ever the food at the
roosevelt is putting a smile on people's
faces
try and bunch them up a little bit just
make it look so much neater including
tinas breathe and talk and okay i've got
this awesome
we're in a nice rotation here
john and tina are a great team when they
communicate properly
okay and i think the buzz they get from
tonight will encourage them to keep
working on their relationship how you
doing we're rocking along here
i love it plates are going away
it's the best thing i've ever had
well done okay how'd you feel
where's john well done ah thank you
first time you've actually cooked yes
yeah from scratch from scratch for an
amazing wedding well done both you thank
you
it's been a great night thanks to john
and tina's teamwork
you guys did it even ahead of schedule
you can do this i'm really hoping that
our future with misty and our wedding
business just goes through the roof time
to go
it'll be a bit sad to leave this place
i think john
and tina then have bloody good job
tonight
and more importantly i think
the whole wedding has opened their eyes
the huge potential they've got here
tonight the roosevelt is fully booked
for the first time in years and the inn
is back on course for success
it's been a hell of a week yes tonight
prove that you both can pull this off
once we got the system going it won't
work very well stick together
all right we'll do it light glue you've
got every chance now good luck you can
have a happy happy ever after let me
tell you thank you so much
take care of yourself thank you not
sneak downstairs with that dance floor
not even heading in that direction nice
[Music]
oh man
so gorgeous oh my gosh oh there's an
upstairs thank you gordon ramsay for
giving us this opportunity this
experience obviously is not meant to be
easy but in the end
worth it
so thank you very much it was nice to
say goodbye to him tonight
and i look forward to seeing him again
actually
you